Das riesige Erdbeben in Kalifornien Ist üBerfällig Wird Big one so werden solche mega Beben Genannt
1906 Kam es zum letzten mal zu einem Mega Beben in der region es war die schlimmste naturkatastrophe der usa mit einer erdbebenstärke von
8,46 meter Verschoben Sich Damals die pazifische und die nordamerikanische platte Genauso Viel
Müssten die Beiden Platten Sich Jetzt Wieder Gegeneinander
Verkantet Haben in der letzten woche gab es vier erdbeben entlang des feuerrings der pazifischen platte
und Jetzt Wird Vermutet Dass ein Beben in Kalifornien Bevorstehen Könnte Alles über das drohende
Erdbeben das Mega-Beben in Kalifornien Jetzt Praktisch zum science fiction Herzlich Willkommen
Am 18 april 1906 Um 5 uhr 12 bebte die erde Rund Um San Francisco
Es erreichte eine stärke von 8,4 und zerstörte San Francisco Weitestgehend vor allem die Feuer Nach Dem Erdbeben Waren
Absolut zerstörerisch Ein Großteil der Bevölkerung Wurde obdachlos und 3000 menschen starben ein Weiteres solches Erdbeben Ist Unvermeidlich
Darüber Sind Sich alle Im Klaren Aber Wann Wird es stattfinden Wenn man Sich die verschiebung der ErDplatten von Damals ansieht
müsste es Schon Bald so weit sein 6 zentimeter Pro Jahr Verschieben Sich die pazifische und die
nordamerikanische platte gegeneinander Bezogen Auf das Erdbeben von 1906 Sind es also Jetzt Schon 60
Zentimeter Mehr Als Damals Aber
Ob Ein Erdbeben stattfindet und wo Das hängt von so Vielen faktoren Ab Das Sind
Wissenschaftler und wissenschaftlerinnen einfach Nichts Dazu Sagen Können oder Wollen doch Jetzt
Schrillen die Alarmglocken in der letzten woche gab es vier erdbeben Rund Um die pazifische platte es bebte Auf Neuseeland InDonesien
Japan Und Dem ozeanischen
Vanuatu und Dabei Hatten die Beben in mexiko damit Wahrscheinlich üBerhaupt Nichts zu Tun Denn dort bebte die erde Entlang der
Karibischen und der cocos platte das muster der Beben entlang der pazifischen platte war Dabei Sehr
Ungewöhnlich wie seismologen Gary Gibson von der universität Melbourne
Festgestellt Hat in der Daily mail Aus trader Sagt er
diese ungewöhnliche Muster Zeigen Sich öfter und scheinen Nicht vollkommen
Zufällig Wir Können uns Aber noch Keinen reim Darauf Machen Mit Anderen Worten
Nichts Genaues weiß Man Nicht es scheint so als ob Sich die beben durch seismische
Wellen Entlang des rings of fire des feuerrings Rund Um die pazifische platte
Gegenseitig Ausgelöst Hätten der Feurigen der Wird so Genannt da Entlang der kante der pazifischen platte immer wieder Vulkane Ausbrechen
Durch die bruchkante Kann Manchmal Sehr leicht an die erdoberfläche Gelangen ob Aber diese Jetzt
Festgestellten Seismischen aktivitäten ein Erdbeben in Kalifornien
Auslösen Können Dass es vollkommen unsicher nur Eins Ist Sicher es Wird dort in Kalifornien ein Erdbeben Geben und es Wird Heftig sein
Aber Ob Es nächste woche Nächstes Jahr Oder in den NäChsten 10
Dann Passieren Wird Das Kann Niemand Sagen Wenn es neue erkenntnisse
Dazu gibt erfahrt ihr es Natürlich Hier bei pixum wenn ihr Kein video zum thema und auch zu Allen Anderen Themen Verpassen Wollt Dann sollten
Wir hier ein Abo auf saure und vergesslich Den
Genau Auf die glocke Hier geht es Weiter Mit
Erdbeben in deutschland da Geht es Um die gefahr von Erdbeben Hier in deutschland die gibt es nämlich Auch Ja und ansonsten Bis Dann
Bleibt Dran